aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un plat
qu'on a dans déguster en famille ou
entre amis quand il fait froid comme
aujourd'hui encore plus quand il y a de
la neige ou qu'on est à la montagne et
les ingrédients de base de la
charcuterie des pommes de terre des
cornichons et bien sûr du fromage vous
allez deviner la raclette alors qu'il a
inventé les Français les Suisses quel
est le meilleur fromage à raclette
direction l'atelier je vous raconte
l'histoire secrète de la raclette oui il
fait pas chaud on va se régaler
[Musique]
il y a une chance sur deux que vous
aimiez la raclette en effet d'après les
chiffres la moitié des foyers français
en consomme chaque hiver en moyenne 3
fois dans la saison une moitié qui aime
mais une moitié qui n'aime pas ils ont
fondu les plombs bon ce qui n'aime pas
vous pouvez quand même rester car vous
allez le voir l'histoire de ce plat est
étonnante faire fondre du fromage près
d'une source de chaleur c'est une idée
qui ne date pas d'hier dans les Alpes
françaises beaucoup de paysans avaient
l'habitude de faire rôtir du fromage au
coin du feu mais la raclette celle que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui nous vient
du Valais un canton du sud de la Suisse
son origine remonterait au Moyen-Âge
une légende raconte qu'après avoir
rentré leur troupeau des bergers ce
serait rassemblé autour du feu
du greloton de froid ils auraient décidé
de faire fondre le fromage sur des
pierres disposées autour du feu alors
qu'ils avaient l'habitude de le manger
froid et il l'aurait mangé chaud pour se
réchauffer
cette technique de cuisson est
mentionnée pour la première fois à la
fin du 16e siècle dans les notes d'un
médecin suisse de la ville de Sion il
décrit le plein avec des mots très
élogieux il le dit
savoureux dira doux et tendre à la
presse saveur
ça donne envie traditionnellement les
paysans utilisaient un fromage à base de
lait cru de vache à pâte
mignure qu'on appelle tout simplement le
valet du nom du canton dans lequel il
est produit à l'époque on faisait
toujours fondre le fromage dans la
cheminée les montagnards le faisait
ensuite couler sur des pommes de terre
en raclant à l'aide d'une spatule ou
d'un couteau d'où le nom raclette qui
n'apparaît officiellement qu'en 1874
mais il ne désigne à l'époque que le
fromage
[Musique]
au fil du temps les visiteurs de passage
dans le Valais et découvrent se plat
certes un peu lourd mais délicieux petit
à petit la raclette envahit les tables
des milieux aisés mais aussi surprenant
que cela puisse paraître il a fallu de
longues années à la raclette pour
conquérir la France elle ne passe la
frontière Suisse qu'en 1973 cette
année-là le commercial d'une célèbre
marque de fromage découvre la raclette
il comprend très vite le parti que sur
notre entreprise peut en tirer de
l'autre côté des Alpes il lance donc la
production du célèbre fromage dans
l'Hexagone puis il teste le plat dans
les stations de ski alors en plein essor
et ça marche le succès est-elle qu'en
1978 le premier appareil individuel à
six poêlons celui que nous connaissons
tous sort sur le marché son succès est
immédiat mais ce n'était pas gagné car
cet appareil n'a rien de rustique en
revanche il est très pratique plus
besoin d'acheter une demi meule de
fromage ou d'aller au restaurant pour
déguster une raclette en plus il est
très convivial et en quelques temps
l'appareil devient le cadeau idéal à
offrir pour les anniversaires ou les
mariages bon maintenant passons aux
choses sérieuses une bonne raclette ça
vous dit alors direction les cuisines
c'est par là
pour la réussir il faut commencer par
choisir de bons produits et pour
commencer de la bonne charcuterie
jambon sec rosette viande des grisons
vous pouvez même ajouter du jambon de
Paris si le cœur vous en dit en fait la
palette est extrêmement large le gros
avantage avec la raclette c'est que vous
pouvez l'adapter au goût de chacun tenez
si vous êtes végétarien par exemple vous
pouvez parfaitement remplacer la
charcuterie par des légumes grillés des
poivrons par exemple des brocolis du
chou-fleur des champignons ils se
marient très bien avec le fromage fondu
ensuite il faut choisir les pommes de
terre
des pommes de terre à chair ferme comme
l'Amandine ou la charlotte elle tienne
mieux lors de la cuisson et ne se frites
pas au premier coup de couteau petit
conseil ne retirez pas la peau pour les
faire cuire vous perdez jusqu'à 90% des
vitamines une fois cuite vous les
disposez dans un plat qui ne craint pas
la chaleur en ajoutant un petit peu
d'eau au fond lorsque notre appareil
raclette sera chaud nous poserons le
plat dessus ça évitera de manger des
patates froides pour finir le plus
important bien sûr le fromage
alors pour faire une raclette dans les
règles de l'art il faut utiliser le
fromage dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure le raclette du Valais c'est une
appellation d'origine protégée il s'agit
d'un fromage à pâte mûre je l'ai dit
produit à base de lait cru de vache
affinés 3 à 6 mois les tomes du Valais
font en moyenne 6 kg et son parfois fumé
ou agrémentés de poivre ou d'herbe ce
qui leur donne un arôme à la fois corsé
et fleuri bon autant vous le dire tout
de suite ce n'est pas facile à dénicher
j'ai fait quatre fromageries et j'en ai
pas trouvé ouais bon on va pas en faire
tout un fromage non ça marche aussi très
bien avec de la raclette de Savoie
qu'elle soit nature fumée ou au poivre
on peut aussi utiliser du morbier ou de
l'abondance cette délicieux l'important
c'est que votre fromage est du goût et
soit onctueux pour fondre correctement
et pour ça mieux vaut en acheter moins
mais du bon en privilégiant les produits
de votre fromager voilà je crois qu'il
ne manque rien c'est presque prêt
l'avantage avec la raclette et moi
j'aime ça c'est qu'elle demande pas trop
de boulot à celui qui la prépare c'est
vrai qu'une fois les produits achetés
les pommes de terre cuites c'est
l'appareil qui fait tout le travail du
coup si vous aimez la variété mieux vaut
utiliser un appareil à raclette
classique un appareil à poil long
ça c'est le mien un appareil tout à fait
classique bon il a un peu vécu il est
composé d'une résistance d'un plateau
juste au dessus qui permet de réserver
la chaleur et de poser les pommes de
terre pour les tenir au chaud et puis
bien sûr des petits poisons allez c'est
parti allez chauffe Marcel si comme moi
vous raffolez de la raclette pourquoi
pas vous inscrire à la raclette Cup elle
est organisée chaque année par des
étudiants de Chambéry en Savoie en 2021
ils ont établi à record plus de 1000
d'entre eux se sont partagés une
raquette géante sans dix appareils à
raclette 400 kg de pommes de terre 410
kg de fromage et 9000 tranches de
charcuterie
je crois que c'est bon
[Musique]
pour patienter j'ai une petite devinette
pour vous savez-vous qui détient le
record de la plus grosse meule de
fromage à raclette
vous avez une petite idée et oui sans
surprise ce sont des Suisses en 2004 ils
ont réalisé une meule de tenez-vous bien
135 kg ça fait un fromage d'un mètre 23
de diamètre cela représente 2000
tranches de fromage de quoi passer une
bonne soirée raclette
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a mis en appétit n'hésitez pas
à liker à vous abonner à la chaîne et
puis si vous vous posez des questions
sur certains plats ou certains aliments
inscrivez-les en commentaire je ne ferai
un plaisir d'y répondre dans une
prochaine vidéo sur la planche tenez il
y a quelques semaines par exemple j'en
ai fait une sur les frites aller voir ça
va vous plaire allez à très bientôt sur
la chaîne des épicurieux et régalez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]